the oscar slab heard round the world
tarzan were you watching and what did
you think yes i was watching but i
thought it was fake yeah i thought it
was staged at first as well but of
course we know that it was not and that
traumatizing moment was the final straw
for this year's host wanda
sykes oh wow
when you think back if you were asked to
do it again to host again
would you host again oh hell no
i don't know if i if i would want to do
it again it's a huge job and you know it
took a lot of people to
you know clean me up three and a half
months later wanda is still recovering
from the incident she explained to kelly
and ryan it was just you couldn't
believe it yeah couldn't believe it
shocked shocked and then it was like
so okay so everybody's just gonna sit
here
right
yeah and then yeah and it was like the
show just kept going on and that then i
would look behind the curtains like he's
still sitting here
so where are will and chris now chris
was spotted on vacation in croatia with
new girlfriend lake bell e.t has learned
he was approached to host this year's
emmy awards but turned down the job why
a source tells us he's quote over
hollywood and hopes to travel and lay
low after his comedy tour
as for will he was last seen in april
flying into mumbai and last we heard he
was going to therapy but we set for life
for life baby will's buddy martin
lawrence confirmed that despite the slap
controversy bad boys 4 is still in the
works he tells ebony magazine quote we
got one more at least back in 1994 e.t
was on set with the guys for the
original film it's my first action film
i don't do all my own stunts i do the
the simpler
[Music]